voici comme villa
[Musique]
comment ça va tirer ma tante a droit à
une musique d'entrée
m alors je m'emballe pas non plus besoin
tout à l'heure il ya eu la répartition
des loges ils m'ont mis dans les
chiottes donc c'est pas gagné cette
semaine c'est un très très beau plateau
thierry félécitations emmanuel petit qui
vient nous voir pour son livre francs
tireurs alors comme vous l'a demandé
j'ai fait le le résumé de son livre
voilà il est juste là
jean michel jarre jean michel jarre
c'est la classe dans les années 70-80
vous étiez considéré comme l'incarnation
du futur au même titre que les bogdanoff
voilà alors c'est sûr que quand on les
voit on dit que le futur a priori
c'était pas la chirurgie esthétique ça
c'est sympa
aujourd'hui c'est génial aussi à pierre
arditi a bien pas bouger physiquement
c'est vrai on a toujours connu vieux
d'ailleurs pour tous ceux qui pensent
que vous avez jamais été jeune vous avez
pas une peinture de vous a dit
frédéric lopez c'est la classe il
inventait plein de super concept
d'émission rendez vous en terre inconnue
c'est lui un tu sais tu prends une star
et tu l'emmènes dans un pays où il
voulait pas aller à la base alors le
rituel 7 bandé les yeux de la star à
l'aéroport pour cacher la destination
bon sauf avec gilbert montagné forcément
non mais à la place si l'ua et bouche et
le nez et
non d'ailleurs et si jamais vous l'effet
rendre vraiment est inconnu avec thierry
lui bander pas les yeux parce que ça va
lui rappeler ses soirées aux chandelles
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
thierry ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
posez mathieu madénian vous allez
commencer dans la série un gars une
fille mais vous voyez toujours de dos ça
fait quoi d'avoir le même début de
carrière que clara morgane
c'est vraiment une merde mais je t'aime
même si j'en garde à propos de vote qui
vous avait twitté ce bouquin c'est comme
un marmot je me suis sentie comme une
foule neuf mois en couveuse et il est
sorti à terme alors j'ai envie de vous
demander comment va votre four pas
justement je vais bientôt 50 berne va
falloir que je subisse une coloscopie
alors savoir fusion cela fait un peu
derrière la foule ok
laurence boccolini vous êtes fait
tatouer dans le cookie semis si vous
faites un tatouage dans le bas du dos ça
sera quoi alors
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus